é a creche como instituição dedicada à
primeira infância e concebida a partir
de fóruns públicos situados na sociedade
civil foi o trabalho de pesquisa que eu
realizei no meu pós-doutorado
foi sob a supervisão da professora maria
tereza elemento anda faculdade de
educação e coordenadora do lepad bom
porque que justifica essa pesquisa né no
atual momento
a creche hoje né ela faz parte da
primeira etapa da educação básica então
ela é a porta de entrada das crianças e
das famílias no contexto escolar
segunda a segunda justificativa é que a
educação é um dos elementos que
estrutura uma sociedade é então
estruturar a primeira etapa da educação
né
e dá continuidade a esse projeto
contribui com uma estruturação de uma
sociedade
o segundo ponto é que a educação
infantil é o melhor a educação é um
patrimônio público da humanidade então a
educação precisa ser cuidada por todos
nós
e o terceiro é inserir a educação no
contexto da pós-modernidade né
ou seja é conceber as creches a partir
de fóruns públicos situados na sociedade
civil
ou seja é é importante que a sociedade é
dialogue sobre esse tema que é um tema
complexo que diz respeito a todos nós e
que precisa é ser repensado porque a
creche por muito tempo ela fez parte da
assistência então hoje ela é parte da
educação então tem é um trabalho
complexo de aprendizado dessas crianças
e dessas famílias que precisa ser
dialogado com a sociedade é pra esse
entendimento
bom nesse contexto
isto que nós formulamos o nosso projeto
nosso problema da pesquisa né em que
medidas a prática democrática
possibilita uma com uma comunidade
contribuir com uma nova concepção sobre
a instituição creche é pensando é como
nós pensamos nesse problema né nós
elaboramos a então o objetivo é conhecer
o que os membros da sociedade civil
propõe como um projeto de educação
infantil alinhado às características do
contexto atual de sua comunidade então
como a sociedade e em geral né tensa a
educação infantil então que se esses
essas pessoas né do grupo específico
pensão é e ajudam a construir um projeto
em educação
bom pra isso nós realizamos né pra
coleta dessas informações desses dados
dessa troca
nós organizamos um workshop né esse
workshop
nós tivemos inscritos 48 para
participantes
esses participantes eles é vinham né da
comunidade da unicamp como também da
comunidade externa e fizeram parte
professores gestores da educação
infantil pais de crianças é alunos do
curso de pedagogia e não alunos do curso
da pedagogia e pessoas especialistas na
área e pessoas interessadas pelo tema
bom pra a agente receber essas pessoas
né que algumas conheciam a educação
infantil é o trabalho das creches outras
não
nós organizamos um contexto pra provocar
essa comunidade para têm sites para que
a gente pudesse discutir sobre o tema
então nós organizamos ambanis do
cotidiano das creches um mapa conceitual
e fotografias
a infância e aqui nós temos né então
algumas fotografias do workshop né nós
tivemos a parceria nem o apoio do concen
é da pró reitoria de pesquisa do
instituto de computação e da faculdade
de educação então aqui a nós temos os
banners com imagens do cotidiano das
creches
aqui nós temos um mapa conceitual então
os participantes puderam responder é que
a educação infantil para o nosso tempo
né a a partir de de uma palavra o
cotidiano das creches né dos trabalhos
desenvolvidos
lá os projetos e e esse grupo não é nós
dividimos em cinco grupos e cada um com
7 6 11 12 participantes
bom é esse grupo teve a possibilidade a
partir de 13 instrumentos de pensar
sobre a educação infantil esses
instrumentos eles são do design
participativo né a quem nos ajudou
diretamente acolher esses dados foi a
professora cecília banal se que o
professor é roberto pereira é e que nos
orientou também na utilização desses
instrumentos então mapa conceitual o
storytelling e o banho haiti
o mapa conceitual é como nós já vimos é
a partir de uma pergunta o participante
responde com uma palavra ou com um
conjunto de palavras o storytelling é os
participantes puderam contar uma
história da sua infância tanto positiva
como negativa é pra quebrar o gelo pra
gente continuar cobrindo o haiti eo
brasil haiti é uma técnica que também à
parte
de uma pergunta escrita né
os participantes é escrevem uma resposta
e essa resposta é partilhada né então eu
inicio a resposta logo em seguida vem
uma outra resposta uma uma continuação
da resposta com outro ponto de vista
então esses foram os instrumentos para
coletas de dados e os resultados é o que
nós percebemos mapa conceitual então
parece né educação criança ea qualidade
e respeite enfim
então a sociedade já percebe que a
creche hoje ela é a primeira etapa da
educação e tem um trabalho a ser r é a
ser feito neste espaço criança né num
mapa conceitual final né criança
educação/formação comprometida
aprendizado então o workshop de outros
elementos também pra ser pensado é nessa
educação de forma mais ampla e que
precisa de um professor formado é que
precisa da participação de uma família e
que lá é um contexto de aprendizado e os
resultados referentes ao estoque
storytelling foram histórias das
vivências das crianças da dos
participantes é histórias que nos
fizeram também refletir as boas
experiências e as experiências não tão
boas em educação para que a gente possa
pensar em nas estratégias posteriores e
obrigou haiti é que a partir da pergunta
o que é educar uma criança na sociedade
contemporânea né
nós chegamos aí há duas categorias a
mostradas pelos participantes
a concepção de educação então a creche
tem uma concepção de educação que é uma
comunidade de aprendizado de todos né é
uma prática pedagógica então que a
seja um contexto de aprendizado para as
crianças que têm um professor formado
que os ambientes seja para o
desenvolvimento dessa criança pequena de
0 a 3 anos que não seja um espaço é de
escolarização mas sim de aprendizado e
concluindo então né
uma proposta de educação infantil devem
para implicar numa prática pedagógica
que possibilite o aprendizado de todos é
a formação do profissional é
extremamente importante porque vai estar
ali educando diretamente essa criança é
ea participação também das famílias né e
à fala de um dos participantes para a
gente terminar que a educação deve estar
além das propostas verticalmente
impostas mais construída por todos os
que fazem na prática é então é a
importância é de dela da da criação de
um projecto pensado então por toda a
sociedade e principalmente por aqueles
que estão 11 no contexto das creches e
da educação infantil
né a educação é um processo contínuo e
sem fim é essa é uma pesquisa que a
gente pretende dar continuidade né
apresentar para os municípios que têm
nos procurado para que ajudem sá
elaboração dos seus projectos de
educação as suas diretrizes curriculares
e cria deixar o meu agradecimento porque
uma pesquisa a gente não faz sozinha é é
a pró reitoria de pesquisa da unicamp e
professora gláucia pastore ao professor
jurandir é coordenador do concen a
professora carmem lavras coordenadora do
nep fpex professora maria tereza
professora sicília bananal fica o
professor roberto ea fundação antônio
antonieta se entra gordinho que acedeu
todas as imagens
muito obrigada